this week on brian ross investigates
call strike three
baseball blues the overdose death of a
los angeles angels pitcher tyler skaggs
leads to some ugly truths
eight major league players took the
stand during the trial five admitting
they got pills from kay a new drug
scandal hits america's pastime when
players and owners can't even agree on
when the season should start acclaimed
sports journalist jane levy brings us
the latest
plus trouble down on the ranch cattle
ranchers going out of business they're
dropping like flies we are losing cattle
ranchers at an alarming rate price of
meat at the grocery store is at an
all-time high but the ranchers are
seeing very little of that
well sometimes nothing and sometimes
just
i hate to say it but peanuts and this
week's winners and losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of media height
from the studios of the law and crime
trial devil in new york city's herald
square
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined by
my colleague rhonda schwartz and rhonda
we begin tonight with the baseball blues
not only are negotiations between owners
and players likely to delay the start of
this year's season but the sport has
been rocked by a new drug scandal it's
all coming to light now following the
overdose death of a los angeles pitcher
tyler skaggs and testimony in a recent
court trial about widespread use among
other players rhonda that's right brian
a member of the los angeles angel staff
eric k has been found guilty of
providing skags with counterfeit
fentanyl-laced pills
essentially acting as an in-house drug
dealer for the baseball team he faces a
minimum of 20 years in prison
a former los angeles angels employee has
been convicted in tyler skagg's death
nearly three years after the pitcher
overdosed and died in a south lake hotel
room he faces 20 years in prison and
will be sentenced in june skaggs an
angel standout pitcher was found dead in
his hotel room in july 2019 prior to a
series against the texas rangers
prosecutors argued it was kay who last
spoke to skaggs the night he died and
supplied the 27 year old with
counterfeit oxycodone containing
fentanyl
we're obviously disappointed in the
verdict we thought there were many
reasons to doubt the government's case
eight major league players took the
stand during the trial five admitting
they got pills from kay referring to him
as the go-to guy for pain pills so to
get a better understanding of the impact
of all this we're joined by the
acclaimed sports journalist jane levy
author of books on mickey mantle sandy
koufax and her latest babe ruth the big
fella
jane thank you for being here tonight
the trial of the los angeles angels
staff member made big headlines with a
number of other players testifying about
widespread use of opiates but was it a
big surprise to you
drug use among healthy young
males who played sports as never a
surprise to me and unfortunately what it
did it at a time when nobody's playing
baseball or planning to play baseball is
it reignited memories of the cocaine
scandals of the 70s or the pittsburgh
pirates and it pointed up exactly what
is the matter with major league baseball
right now they're always behind in
fixing problems that they should have
addressed beforehand so for example
skaggs death obviously um caused uh
in addition to great pain to a lot of
people
a change in mlb policy up till then they
didn't test for opioids and a new report
in the washington post suggests that the
opioid use isn't actually rampant uh
since they started testing in uh two
years ago
mlb is some 12
169 drug tests in the last two years and
of those they nabbed 15 steroid users
and zero opioid users and the minor
leagues they confirmed the numbers and
they've been doing the same kind of
testing but for much longer than for two
decades and there's almost no opioid
opioid use reflected in those numbers
jane as you know from your coverage of
so many uh baseball figures and the
sport itself these players play with a
lot of pain often is that the reason
they would turn to opiates is it pain or
is it simply for pleasure
actually the history of drug use in
clubhouses and it being
you know made easier by clubhouse
attendance and what they what they call
clubbies goes back a long way
it used to be amphetamines greenies is
what they call them and often in a in a
major league clubhouse you would see a
bowl of them just sitting around
available
next to the the sun flower seeds and the
and the bubble gum and so
this is not a new phenomenon that that
somebody is there to help them it was
rampant greenies are rampant for 40
years starting right after expansion of
major league baseball and the increase
in travel and the hours on the road for
these guys the season is grueling and it
has gotten longer and longer thanks to
extra layers of playoffs
and
they're zigzagging all over the country
between time zones and they're exhausted
they're worn out by august everybody's
injured and i think it's treating as
much um
the breakdown of their bodies as it is
treating pain
jane a question for you from ronda
schwartz rhonda
tens of thousands die from fentanyl and
opioid overdoses
why is it important to pay attention to
a major league baseball player's death
i think it's you know it is sad to say
but in a way it can be useful in
pointing out just how
endemic this has become an epidemic it
has become if it's happening in major
league baseball people might sit up and
pay attention the unfortunate flip side
to that rhonda is that
right now when major league baseball is
doing everything it can to basically
you know commit suicide
with another foolish labor stoppage that
means the spring training games are not
starting next week and nobody's reported
to spring training except minor leaguers
it's one more way in which it makes
clear that baseball is always behind
three steps behind in dealing with
issues that everybody knows exists
jane one question i have is it seems
likely that others on the team in
management at the los angeles angels
must have had some idea of what was
going on is that's the next shoe to drop
here
i would guess that some players knew
whether the management was insulated i i
know tim mead who was one of the guys
who's been you know implicated in this
he's a wonderful guy
that would surprise me a lot he's a very
decent human being um
i think they would shelter the the
people upstairs but that it happens
is not at all surprising and they don't
have in place the testing and they
haven't had place the testing or the
medical care or the
counseling the you know the rehab that
people need it was the same thing when
mickey mantle was drinking too much it
was to say you know in the 50s they're
always behind and now they've got a
situation where they have medical staffs
you know teen doctors paying for the
right to say they're the team doctors so
it's a completely corrupt system in
which
players can't trust that they're getting
confidential or competent care
and so you think there's still a wide
gap there between what should be done
and what's being done
absolutely
all right jane levy the acclaimed sports
journalist thank you so much for joining
us here tonight
my pleasure
up next hamburger prices at an all-time
high at the grocery store so why are so
many cattle ranchers going out of
business
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
we turn now to trouble down on the farm
where cattle ranchers are up in arms
about what they say in a lawsuit are the
dirty tricks of the big four packing
houses keeping prices for beef and pork
high for consumers while allegedly
conspiring to keep the prices they pay
the ranchers artificially low
american shoppers know the price of
hamburger is at a record high
but what they may not know is that very
little of the money they spend for
hamburger ends up in the hands of
american cattle ranchers many of them
are being forced out of business
and we're joined now by bill bullard in
billings montana he's the ceo of a
non-profit group that represents
american cattle ranchers mr bullard
thanks for being here with those
hamburger prices at an all-time high it
must be a great time to be a cattle
rancher
that's what consumers would be led to
believe but it's exactly the opposite
consumers are paying super inflated
prices for beef while cattle prices are
receiving seriously depressed prices for
cattle many of them not able to recover
even their cost of production from the
marketplace
so what's going on that makes that the
case
well we have four packers controlling 85
percent of the marketplace they have a
stranglehold on the market they're able
to leverage down prices we have alleged
a lot in a lawsuit that they have
actually conspired to artificially
depress prices paid to cattle producers
while at the same time inflating beef
prices for consumers
so you're saying they get together to
decide what the price should be
that's exactly what our lawsuit alleges
that they have colluded conspired
uh to uh gain an advantage in the
marketplace at the expense of cattle
producers on one end of the supply chain
and consumers on the other
and who are the four big packers that
you're focused on
they are tyson cargill
jbs
and marfrigg and both jbs and marfrigg
are brazilian-owned companies so two of
the four largest packers that control 85
percent of the fed cattle market are in
fact foreign owned
this month jbs agreed to a 52 million
dollar settlement with the department of
justice to settle a federal anti-trust
lawsuit
the company did not admit any liability
but its background has long raised
questions about its ethics
started decades ago by a small-time
butcher in brazil jbs has now grown into
a multi-billion dollar worldwide beef
poultry and pork producer the largest in
the world
but the two brothers who now run the
company have been connected to a massive
bribery scheme in brazil
joe maxwell is a long time spokesperson
for cattle ranchers and family farmers
there was a lot of illicit behavior
bribing of 1800 politicians
in order to bolster
a loan through the brazilian government
so they could enter the u.s markets and
they have continually been
a corrupt organization demonstrating
corrupt practices from top to bottom
well we allege they're a part of the
conspiracy um we know when they came to
the united states we tried to urge the
justice department to block them from
trying to merge and acquire many of our
domestic beef packing plants but we were
ignored
in washington a bipartisan bill that
would cut the power of the big four
packing companies has now been
introduced
we're joined now by senator charles
grassley republican from iowa and
senator grassley thank you for being
with us here this evening can you help
our viewers understand the issue for
american consumers and american ranchers
when it comes to beef prices
you know
well i'm kind of surprised that
one of these companies paid 52 million
dollars for price fixing that case goes
back to 2015.
beef is higher now than it's ever been
before i can't say that their price
fixing today
but i can say this that the cattle
feeder
the person that produces this meat
particularly if he's a family farmer in
iowa as opposed to the big feedlots in
texas kansas and colorado
that
that this
cattle feeder is not making any money
and some days he can't even get a market
and if he gets a market it's maybe 30
days down the road and this is this way
because four big companies
uh dominate the market by about 85 uh
percent of the daily kill
and uh and with their cozy relationships
between these big feedlots in the states
i said
and those feedlots contract ahead
then the family farmer
it's difficult for them to get a market
when about 90 percent of that daily kill
is already uh marketed and so we have a
lot of farmers in iowa and nebraska and
the midwest generally that don't like to
contract ahead some do but most don't so
for americans who are going to the
supermarket to buy their meat they see
the prices going up yet the family
farmers aren't making any money
they are not
or if they are they're making just a
little bit and yet we have these four
big packers making fantastic profits so
the packers are making up to eighteen
hundred dollars ahead what is the family
farmer making ahead
well sometimes nothing and sometimes
just
i hate to say it but peanuts
senator grassley whose family has long
farmed in iowa where he sometimes
pitches in when back home says jbs got
off easy with its justice department
settlement
compared to their profits how much is
that 52 million dollars
oh very well you can imagine a peanuts
again
senator grassley you and i have known
each other for more than 50 years now
well before your united states senator
and all this time you've always been
fighting for the family farmer
is it a losing battle
no it won't be there's still plenty of
room for the family farmer hey i
wouldn't give up on the family farm at
all but many cattle ranchers have had to
give up they're dropping like flies we
are losing cattle ranchers at an
alarming rate we've lost over half a
million already in just the past four
decades our industry is in a serious uh
contraction and if something isn't done
immediately the american rancher will no
longer look like what it is today the
industry
bill bullard thank you so much for being
with us here tonight
my pleasure thank you
jbs declined to have one of their
officers appear on our program tonight
but in a statement the company denies
any alleged wrongdoing and says it
settled the federal government's
anti-trust lawsuit only to avoid
excessive litigation costs the company
says it always acts in good faith and it
says in full compliance with the law
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media we'll check out the choices
made by the editors of mediaite you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aida mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group
and aiden you've chosen as the winner
this week jim schuette at cnn a reminder
of the importance of cnn at a time of
international crisis
that's right so jim schutto is a cnn
anchor he's actually been anchoring his
show from kiev in ukraine this week and
he posted a very worthwhile twitter
thread in response to those in american
media who have been praising vladimir
putin this week the thread was an
incomplete accounting of the various
opposition leaders dissidents and
civilians that putin has targeted
poisoned and even murdered it's not the
kind of threat that should be necessary
to post i don't think but this week fox
news host tucker carlson asked on air
why americans should not like putin
i think jim shootout provided a very
convincing answer to that question with
that threat and shooter was one of my
colleagues when i was at abc and in my
view abc fools let him leave for cnn
where he's been a real star a solid
straight shooting reporter
that's right and as you noted he is a
really good reminder of what cnn can
truly do it's one of the only true
international
uh news outlets like the bbc and jim
schudo who has had a remarkable career
as a foreign correspondent at abc at pbs
at cnn he also served as senior advisor
to the u.s ambassador to china under
president barack obama so he has an
incredible career covering this kind of
stuff and when you see his reporting
from kiev in ukraine that really seeps
through you can really tell that this is
someone who knows what he's talking
about and is delivering very compelling
reporting from over there so it's great
that we have reporters like that uh
covering these sort of conflicts abroad
and as you have said to me before this
is a time when cnn really shines
that's right they are truly one of the
only international news outlets that we
have and they have 24-hour coverage they
have a big team in ukraine covering this
sort of crisis um and so it's something
that cnn can do really really well and
it's great to see them do that and
honestly i prefer it far more than some
of the other coverage that you see on
cnn that they get criticized for which
are you know the large panels dissecting
the latest thing that trump said
let's turn now to this week's uh loser
chosen by the editors at mediaite
candice owens tell us about her and what
she has to say along this same line of
inquiry
right so i just wanted to point out how
different our winner and loser are this
week
jim sciutto who is a journalist with
decades of experience as a foreign
correspondent uh and then you have
candace owens who is a political pundit
uh who has uh made a name for herself uh
as sort of a pro-trump flamethrower in
recent years um she has now has a show
at the daily wire which is the website
that was founded by ben shapiro and she
developed quite a following
in any case she drew a lot of unwanted
attention this week for a tweet in which
he claimed that putin is actually right
about ukraine
and that his invasion of a sovereign
country
is actually america's fault
now
i am all for pundits criticizing america
and its foreign policy that is something
that journalists should do uh repeatedly
and and be dedicated to doing um what
owens did here is she looked at uh
putin's speech about ukraine which was
you know as dark and a-historical as it
comes
and essentially concluded that ukraine
as a state does not have the right to
exist uh and she said putin is right and
america is at fault here for this
invasion it's not only misinformed it's
an approval uh and a defense of a an
invasion uh that is entirely putin's
decision uh that is going to end up
costing a lot of innocent lives uh so
you know it's kind of a shameful thing
to be posting about on twitter um and
also i should say at the end of the day
if you ever find yourself saying
if you want to know what's really going
on here listen to this speech from putin
which is what candace owen said in this
tweet you should reconsider right her
words were we capital w capital e are at
fault and as you say at a time like this
it's important for american journalists
to raise questions and challenge the
administration we all know what happened
in vietnam and iraq where misinformation
led us into disastrous situations even
so how are you seeing the reporting
going so far as we approach a near world
war three
you know i think the reporting's
actually been quite good uh you know the
press gets a lot of criticism um and in
fact one of the most prominent critics
this week was edward snowden uh who said
that he was you know disgusted to see
the american media rooting for war uh
now i actually asked jim shiuto about
that i interviewed him last week and he
said that
no american media wants war because he
has a foreign correspondent he's seen
war up close and it's bloody and it's
deadly and it's horrific uh and i think
that that's an unfair smear of american
media i don't think anyone's rooting for
war and i think american media overall
has done a pretty good job of covering
it um you know the same cannot be said
for russian media which uh has uh you
know particularly rt has some different
incentives right aidan mclaughlin
editor-in-chief of media thank you so
much for being with us here again
tonight
thanks brian and thanks to all of you
for joining us we'll see you again back
here next week have a good evening
[Music]
do
[Music]
you